good morning Hank it's Tuesday I really
liked your video on Friday about how to
make friends in adulthood and today I
thought I would follow up with some
personal experience on the topic I like
to spend time by myself like most of my
hobbies are things generally done alone
reading writing gardening listening to
podcasts contemplating the relationship
between myself and the bacteria that
colonized me and also I get anxious in
situations with lots of new people not
primarily because of my mental illness I
don't think but because lots of people
find social engagements nervous making
especially when you're going to them
alone
and that also means I'm often not like
my best self in those situations like
I'm often self-conscious about how much
I'm talking or how little or how much
I'm sweating or whatever and that makes
it difficult to be in the conversation
on the other hand I really like being
with close friends and family I love the
comfort and warmth of those deep
connections and they are super important
to me the problem of course is that if
you don't already have those deep
connections it can be difficult to find
them without putting yourself in those
nervous situations where sweat just
sprouts from your forehead like so many
seeds out of well tilled soil and then
in part because you're nervous you
struggle to engage deeply and then you
go home and you're like oh my god I
don't want to do that again so Sarah and
I moved to Indianapolis in 2007 and I
knew almost no one here I was what is
sometimes called a trailing spouse
because we'd moved here for Sara's job
she quickly made great friends at work
but I struggled to make friends at work
on account of how I was working alone in
my basement I did try to make friends I
volunteered for things attended events
accepted every invitation all the things
I'd read on the Internet you were
supposed to do to make friends but none
of it worked and I became discouraged
pretty quickly because all of those
social engagements were really draining
and it just seemed like Indianapolis
wasn't the kind of place for me it felt
to me like everyone here had known
everyone else since grade school
and then a few months after moving we
received an invitation to attend the big
annual neighborhood get-together on our
street and I didn't want to go because I
had tried to make friends through social
events and it didn't work plus everyone
on our street was kind of old like 40
and they had like kids and stuff but
Sarah really wanted to go so we did and
as I expected everyone was super old and
had kids and stuff and I was sweaty and
nervous
and struggling to participate fully in
conversations and after about half an
hour I was definitely ready to go but
then a guy came up to me and introduced
himself he was about my age but not my
size he looked like Vince Vaughn and
Vincent D'Onofrio had had a huge baby
his name was Chris and his fiancee
marina was at the party as well and we
all started talking I was still sweaty
and still nervous but we were talking we
talked about Chris's time in the Peace
Corps and my time as a hospital chaplain
we talked about living in Indianapolis
and living on a street full of old
people and then in an awkward moment
near the end of the night I asked for
Chris's number and he gave it to me now
it didn't happen all at once it wasn't
like love at first sight or whatever but
as we began to hang out with Chris and
marina more I began to hate Indianapolis
less they both worked from home at the
time and we would often go out to lunch
together which meant that astonishingly
enough I sort of had work friends marina
was compassionate and incredibly
thoughtful the kind of person who always
makes you feel heard and cared for and
Chris was hilarious and charismatic but
also deeply loyal he knew I was lonely
and so he invited me to join his IndyCar
fantasy league and to come over to his
house to watch TV all the time and so
through my friendship with Chris I made
more friends until eventually I wanted
to stay in Indianapolis for good because
towns are made out of people in the end
and I've come to love a lot of people in
this one I didn't want to go to that
neighborhood party because I'd tried
going to things I'd tried to make
friends and I thought I had failed in
fact though I just hadn't succeeded yet
this week Chris and marina and Sarah and
I are celebrating 11 years of our
friendship and now we are the old people
with kids and stuff at the neighborhood
party and I couldn't be more grateful
Hank I'll see you on Friday